bin gerade extra nach Dortmund gefahren
um hier mal diesen pizzaautomat zu
checken ey geilo Milow Alter die
schnelle Pizzeria schnellste Pizzeria
vom aufbacken zum Reinbeißen in nur 4
Minuten also bei mir im Backofen dauert
das ein bisschen länger als 4 Minuten da
bin ich mal gespannt ob die schmeckt
okay fahren sie ohne Konto fort Salami
Calabrese das nehmen wir denn Margarita
nee das ist auch weg Tonno nee will ich
auch nicht 4,90 € jetzt hier definitiv
für Pizza Margarita ja komm ich muss
Margarita nehmen weil den Rest esse ich
nicht so gerne hier geht der Countdown
runter noch 40 Sekunden dann kommt meine
Pizza raus oh mein Gott WTF geil hallo
ich sag's Ihnen dann so Leute Pizza ist
eingesammelt naja probieren wir mal
schön heiß ist sind wirklich lecker aber
natürlich ist das jetzt keine Weltklasse
Pizza das ist klar sie schmeckt gut für
eure 90 kannst du nicht meckern ja das
muss ich sagen also der Ausflug hier hat
sich gelohnt Erfahrung